شكرا جزيلا لك فدا اذا نرحب بكم مشاهدينا
في هذه النافذه للتحليل العسكري لمجريات
حرب اسرائيل على قطاع غزه فيها نستضيف كما
العاد المحلل العسكري اللواء فايز الدويري
سنتناول عده مستجدات في طوال هذا اليوم
فيما يتعلق باهم المستجدات والاخباريه من
الناحيه بطبيعه الحال العسكريه في ميادين
الصراع والحرب الدائره في قطاع غزه ولكن
قبل ذلك نريد ان نفهم توزع هذه العمليات
على الخارطه التفاعل ترافقنا اليوم سلام
خضر تفضلي سلام شكرا
مياده اذا تستمر المعارك في قطاع غزه على
اكثر من جبهه لكن هناك مستجدات داخل قطاع
غزه وهناك ايضا مستجدات خارج حدود قطاع
غزه على المستوى العسكري نبدا ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي يستمر
باستهداف القطاع من الشمال الى الجنوب
باسلحه مختلفه غارات للطائرات الاسرائيليه
فوق عده مناطق ترافقت اليوم ايضا مع قصف
من البوارج الحربيه على منطقه جنوب القطاع
وفي شمال القطاع هناك تحليق مكثف للطائرات
المروحيه التي ايضا كما يبدو استهدفت عده
مناطق هذه كلها كانت داخل قطاع غزه
بالتوازي اليوم كتائب القسام اطلقت دفعه
كبيره من الصواريخ من داخل قطاع
غزه توجهت الى ما بات يعرف بمنطقه تل ابيب
الكبرى وهي مدينه تل ابيب والتجمعات
الاستيطانيه الكبيره المحاذيه لها من
الغرب على البحر المتوسط وصولا الى الداخل
رامادان هو التجمع الاكبر الذي يسمى ويقع
ضمن تل ابيب الكبرى بتحت كفى تمت اصابتها
بعده صواريخ ريشون ليسيون وايضا السدود
الى القرب من قطاع غزه بمدى صواريخ تراوح
بين 70 م الى 100 م في اقصى مدى من تلك
الدفعات التي اطلقت اليوم هذه الدفعه
اطلقت بينما كان المتحدث العسكري باسم
قوات الاحتلال يقول ان وحدات الجيش
الاسرائيلي المتوغلة
وصلت اليوم الى ما
سماها دانييل هاجار واحده من ابرز غرف
العمليات في غزه هو يقصد في مدينه غزه
وتحدث عن ان القياده في تلك المنطقه بدات
تتهاوى او بمعنى لم تعد متماسكه وكان هناك
حديث على المستوى السياسي ب وجود امكانيه
الذهاب الى مفاوضات لهد انسانيه رفضتها
حركه حماس فقال نتنياهو انه سيدك قطاع غزه
وسيدفع بحماس الى الاستسلام فاتت هذه
الدفعه التي قدرت بنحو
35 صاروخا لتستهدف قلب المناطق
الاسرائيليه شكلت حاله ضعر وايضا يعيش في
المنطقه المستهدفه بصواريخ القسام اليوم
بين ثلاثه الى 3ه ملايين ونصف مليون
اسرائيل لي كانوا تحت رحمه هذه الصواريخ
سنبدا من شمال القطاع ايضا نحن نتحدث عن
تقريبا مناطق اشتباك ثابته منذ
عده ايام على الاقل منذ ان توغلت في
الشمال لا تزال الاشتباكات في جباليا
البلد مستمره في اكثر من منطقه الشيخ
رضوان لا تزال نقطه اشتباك رئيسيه وايضا
في الشيخ رضوان اليوم استهدفت قوات
المقاومه
كتائب عز الدين القسام قوه اسرائيليه
واوقعت فيها اصابات في مدينه غزه ايضا الى
الشمال منها استهدفت مجموعه راجله كتائب
القسام للقوات الاسرائيليه واوقعت قتلى
وجرحى نشير الى
مساله القوات الاسرائيليه كانت قد اعلنت
قبل بضعه ايام انها سيطرت على منطقه بيت
حانون اذا سيطرت على بيت حانون بشكل كامل
وسيطرت على بيت لاهيا بشكل كامل اليوم
افاد مراسل الجزيره اليس كرام ميدانيا بان
الطائرات المروحيه نفذت عده ضربات في
منطقه بيت حنون علما ان الجيش الاسرائيلي
يفترض ان يكون قد توغل اكثر باتجاه جباليا
وايضا باتجاه الشجاعيه التي يقول الجيش
الاسرائيلي انها تشهد معارك ضاريه القسام
يقول ان المعارك في الشجاعيه تتركز في
تقريبا شرق الشجاعيه اي ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي تقدم الى داخل شارع الشجاعيه
ولكنه اضطر للتراجع على ما يبدو
والاشتباكات تسير عند هذه النقطه بالتحديد
من غير المعروف اذا كانت الاستهدافات في
بيت حنون هي ل مجموعات متوغل من كتائب
القسام او ان الجيش الاسرائيلي الذي وصل
الى بدايه حي الشجاعيه يخشى من عمليه
التفاف من كتائب القسام ومهاجمته من
الخلف نقطه اخيره الى ان الجنوب ما يزال
يشهد قتالا واسعا خان يونس بالتحديد
القتال فيها مستمرا والقوات الاسرائيليه
لم تستطع حتى الان احكام الطوق على مدينه
خانيونس والمناطق المحيطه بها ميد هذه
ابرز التطورات طبعا سنسمع معك ومع اللواء
الدويري تحليل لما لما ر صحي شكرا جزيلا
لك سلام اذا بالفعل لواء فايز لدينا عده
تطورات على امتداد هذا اليوم في جبهه
الشمال وتلك الاشتباكات التي احتدمت في
هذه الايام كذلك لدينا الاستهداف الذي تم
من داخل غزه نحو تل ابيب الكبرى وكذلك عدد
الضباط والجنود الذي لازال يسقط بين قتيل
وجريح وبالاضافه الى تطورات اخرى سناتي
على ذكرها في خلال هذه الفقره التحليليه
نبدا بالتطورات في جباليا الشجاعيه الشيخ
رضوان وكذلك حتى بيت حنون عادت الامور
لتكون على مستوى عالي من التصعيد حتى ان
الجانب الاسرائيلي تحدث هنا عن ان المعارك
ضاريه وقاسيه جدا هناك كيف ترى هذه
المرحله يعني خلال ال 48 ساعه وتحدثنا عده
مرات واشرنا بان هذه الفتره هي
فتره التصعيد المحموم من جانب جيش
الاحتلال بال لعده معطيات من
اهمها الحديث او المسار السياسي الذي
يتحدث عن هدنه وبالتالي دائما وابدا عندما
يكون هناك حديث عن مفاوضات الجانب المهاجم
يصعد باقصى ما يمكن خلال ال 48 ساعه بلغت
حج بلغ حجم التصعيد القمه اي انها هي اصعب
الايام بالنسبه للقوات المدافعه كتائب
القسام وبقيه الفصائل بمعنى اخر لم يعد
لدى جيش الاحتلال اي ورقه اضافيه يوظفها
في هذه المعركه اعتمد التدمير الممنهج
واذا سرنا مع الخارطه للمناطق المبنيه
سنجد البدايات دمرت بالكامل سنجد افراط في
استخدام القصف الجوي والمدفعي
بصوره يصعب تصورها رغم كل ذلك لا تزال
المقاومه قادره على خوض معركه دفاعيه
ناجحه رغم كل القصف الذي جرى رغم كل القصف
الذي جرى لم يستطع ان يحرز تقدما واضحا
يستطيع ان يسوقه ويقدمه انا هنا لا اضخم
الامور ولكن اتابع لحظه بلحظه ما يجري على
ارض المعركه هذا الصمود هذا الصمود وهذا
القتال والخسائر التي اشرت لها وفي نظره
سريعه
هل يعلم المشاهد ان اعداد اليات القتال
التي دمرت خلال ال 53 يوم تجاوزت عتبه
الالف اليه مقاتله بالامس كان
998 يوم امس في هذا اليوم تخطى عتبه الالف
وماذا يعني عتبه الالف يعني اكثر من
فرقتين زائد من معدات الفراق هذا لو
تحدثنا به بلغه الارقام لغه الرياضيه
ومتوسط حسابي باعتبار ان ما دمر جارفه
ودبابات وناقلات ويكون المتوسط الحسابي
ثمانيه ا الان نتحدث عن
8000 قتيل
وجريح فقط في معارك الاليات دون الحديث عن
العبوات الناسفه دون الحديث عن تفجير
الانفاق دون الحديث عن قانصه الغول فقط
كالي ودون الحديث عن اشتباكات اذا جيش
الاحتلال دفع فاتوره باهظه لا اتوقع انه
قادرا على الاستمرار في دفعها جمله واحده
اها الان العمليه دخلت العظ الاصابع
المؤلم ام من يتحمل اكثر سيفرض اوراقه
نقطه اضافيه هذا هذا الصمود الاسطوري
للمقاومه وقد يختلف مع البعض في تفسيراته
ولكل رايه انا كمحلل اقول دفع قوات العدو
لارتكاب امر لا اخلاقي امر لا انساني انا
شاهدت فيديو تجريف المقبره مقبره الشيخ
شعان فيو الان ليجد من يجد المبرر لجيش
الاحتلال حول كثافه القصف والتدبير
الممنهج والتهجير الجماعي لكن ان يصل
الانحطاط
الاخلاقي الى مستوى تجريف
المقبره الاموات لم يسلموا من هذا الاجرام
نقطه لو سمحتي لي اكمل جملتي الان لا يمكن
لسائق جارفه انا خدمت 36 سنه في القوات
المسلحه لكن جيشي لديه اخلاق هذا الجيش
فاقد الاخلاق لا يمكن في اي جيش في العالم
ان يقوم سائق جارفه بتجريف هذ هذه المقبره
دون امر سيادي من اعلى المستويات العسكريه
والسياسيه اذا هذا اجرام ممنهج على مستوى
الكيان الصهيوني لا بل ابعد كل من من لا
يدين هذا الاجرام انظري كل من لا يدين هذا
الاجرام في العالم هو شريك في هذا الجرم
وهو فاقد للاخلاق فاقد للانسانيه طيب هذا
ما كنت اريد ان اسالك عنه من الناحيه
الاستراتيجيه عندما يؤمر بتجريف مقبره نحن
هنا نتحدث عن مقبره الشيخ شعبان في منطقه
الساحه عندما تيتم اتخاذ هكذا قرار ما
الهدف الاستراتيجي منه لا يوجد هدف فقد
اشباع او العطش للدماء هذا الجيش مسحت
كرامته بالارض في يوم السابع من اكتوبر
وهو يحاول ان يرمم شضايا هذه الكرامه التي
اصلا غير موجوده وبالتالي هو كان يقول هو
الجيش الذي لا يقهر الجيش الذي هزم وهزم
الان عشرات الالاف من المقاتلين بعد 53
يوم من معركه بريه يحشد لها بمعدل سته فرق
حمله جويه جسر جوي امريكي مفتوح دعم
بريطاني فرنسي ايطالي الماني امريكي
استخباري الى غيره كل ذلك ولا يستطيع ان
يلحق الهزيمه بالقسام لا بل القسام هي
التي تقض مضاجعه اذا هو الان ينتقم لم
يكتفي
لم هذا فقط تصرف لا اخلاقي تصرف جرمي هو
عجز عن مواجهه
المقاتل حاول ان يدمر كل مظاهر الحياه ان
يهجر شاهدنا اكثر من 11000 مجزره رغم ذلك
لم يشفي غله وحقده اتجه الى الاموات ولا
تزال دمائهم تنزف ليست مقابر مر عليها 40
عاما كما هو في عقيدتنا لا يفتح القبر قبل
40 عاما لكنه بسبب الانحطاط الاخلاقي
والدعم المجنون من الدول الغربيه التي
تشارك في هذا الجرم هذه هي النتيجه ط
سننتقل الى صور اخرى ونتحدث عن ما جرى
اليوم من
استهداف تل ابيب الكبرى ومحيط لنقل تل
ابيب ومحيطها بالتالي تل ابيب الكبرى
برشقات صاروخيه وصل عددها في تل ابيب
وحدها 35 رشقه
صاروخيه هذا ياتي في ظل
ان المنطقه فيها غطاء جوي كثيف جدا من
القصف وقصف مدفعي والويه في الميدان على
الارض ورغم ذلك تستمر هذه الرشقات بهذه
الكثافه كيف يمكن للمقاومه القيام بذلك لو
لم تكن المقاومه متماسكه
لا يمكن لها ان تقوم بذلك لو لم تكن هيئه
الركن فاعله لا يمكن ان ان تقوم بذلك لولا
ان منظومه القياده والسيطره متماسكه وتعمل
بصوره مثاليه لا يمكن لها ان تقوم بذلك
هذا جاء ردا على ذلك الاجرام القص قد لا
يقارن 35 صاروخ لا يقارن مع عشرات الاف
القذائف من المدفعيه التي ترسلها امريكا
هل تعلم ان امريكا ارسلت اكثر من 3000 من
ثلاث ثلاث اضعاف اعداد المقاتلين صو
صواريخ وقذائف مدفعيه لكن هذا هو المتاح
للمقاومه فهي تتقن استخدام الاوراق
المحدوده بطريقه ذكيه بطريقه مؤلمه لجيش
الاحتلال انت ذكرتي ان الاعداد الاجماليه
تتراوح ما بين ثلاث الى 3 ونص مليون وضعوا
رهينه وضمن اطار الملاجئ هذه كانت رساله
واضحه انت تتحدث عن ما بعد حماس يقول
وغيره يقول اذا والجانب الامريكي كيربي
اذا سلمت سلا حماس سلاحها ستتوقف الحرب
حماس انا لا اتحدث باسمها لكن من خلال
المتابعه وتصريحات قاده حماس حماس لن تنق
سلاح لن ترفع الرايه البيضاء وحماس قادره
على خوض معركه لاسابيع طويله من خبرتك
العسكريه عندما نتحدث عن اطلاق رشقات
صاروخيه نحن نتحدث عن اماكن مكشوفه يطلق
منها الصواريخ كما شاهدنا في العديد من
الفيديوهات هل هذا صحيح ليس بالضروره
الان الصندوق الاسود شبكه الانفاق تحدثوا
وقالوا ذا كشفنا وكشفنا وكشفنا ليكشف ما
يكشف يوجد 1300 نفق يوجد 500 م من الانفاق
طابق طابقين ثلاثه طوابق اليه اطلاق
الصواريخ وانا هنا بعد
تحليلي في طبيعه الانفاق تختلف هناك انفاق
دفاعيه انفاق هجوميه انفاق لاغراض التصنيع
انفاق للاغراض المبيت عالم كامل مدينه
كامله تحت المدينه هناك بعض الانفاق توجد
بها سكك
تدفع اليه الاطلاق الراجمه تتوقف في نقطه
معينه يفتح غطاء النفق تصعد للاعلى قدر 50
سم تطلق تنزل يعاد تسكير النفق تتحرك الى
نقطه اخرى وبالتالي عندما تم ت تصميم شبكه
الانفاق تم تصميمها بذكاء بناء على
القدرات المواجهه انا عندما اضع خطتي يجب
ان اضعها لي نعم امكانياتي تحدد ني لكن
التحديد الاكبر تسا على الروايه الساليه
فيما يتعلق ب انهاء حوالي 70% من هذه
الانفاق اذا من اين تنطلق هذه الصواريخ
ومن اين يخرج المقاتلون في هذه المكه انه
كشف اكثر من واح الى
2% اشكرك جزي الشكر لواء فايز دويري
الخبير العسكري والمحلل الاستراتيجي على
هذه المعلومات ودائما لنا لقاء في تحليل
دائما لهذه المستجدات الميدانيه نشكر حسن
متابعتكم مشاهدينا وصلنا الى ختام الفقره
العسكريه لتدعي حرب اسرائيل على غزه نعود
الان الى غرفه غرفه الاخبار ومتابعه
متابعه هذه التغطيه المستمره مع الزميله
فده بسيل